[Applause]
here washing back down here's what we've
got you on this week's show
Thomas gets touchy-feely in a full-body
suit
Maclaren teach me how to design a
supercar in virtual reality and gaps
playing 60 seconds at a time in our
games review welcome to swipe from the
headquarters of McLaren Automotive a
little bit later we'll be going behind
the scenes to get a look at some
cutting-edge design technology they've
started using here first though let's
get a quick look at some of the
techniques stories that made headlines
this week
Virgin Galactic has carried out a
successful test flight of its new rocket
for space tourists the VSS unities
flight above the Mojave Desert is the
company's first rocket-powered flight
since the fatal crash of its original
spaceship in 2014 and while we're
talking galactic holiday making the
development of the first luxury hotel in
space has been announced guests at the
Aurora station will be treated to
zero-gravity thrills and stunning views
of Earth for just 6 point 7 million
pounds
developer Orion Spann says the hotel
will open in 2021 posting its first yeah
the year after
Spotify made its stock market debut this
week but the world's number one music
streaming service decided to use a
direct listing approach with no
underwriters that save millions of
dollars in fees but can mean volatile
trading on opening the loss-making
company was valued at around 30 billion
dollars Mark Zuckerberg is due to
testify to hearings next week the
Facebook box would appear in the US
Senate then at the House Energy and
Commerce Committee a day later
Zuckerberg has refused to appear in
front of UK MPs over the recent data
scandal
[Music]
and Kobe is the town most threatened by
workplace automation in the UK research
by Sky News has also found
Northamptonshire as a whole is the most
vulnerable County the East Midlands has
seven of the ten towns most at risk of
losing jobs to robotics and software now
when it comes to wearable technology
you're probably thinking smartwatches
smart glasses that kind of thing but get
this there's a full-body suit originally
designed for gaming that lets the wearer
feel everything happening to them in the
game and bear in mind that could be
taking bullets from an enemy always the
glutton for punishment we sent Thomas to
try it out
innovations in gaming feel like a weekly
occurrence but one firm is taking a
quantum leap into the future when it
comes to the immersive experience
Tesla suit have created a bodysuit that
promises to take the next step in
virtual reality gaming providing users
with full-body haptic feedback meaning a
user can feel what is happening to their
character in game a fully immersive
experience that I'm here to try out the
suit has a suite of capabilities
built-in motion capture that turns your
body into the controller climate control
to immerse a user further into the
gaming world and Fire metrics that track
heartbeat so game responds better song
with Demetri from Tesla suit Demetri how
how does it work basically we have
haptic feedback which is based on
electrical stimulation and it covers all
of these areas all the way around and
it's directional so it's when something
happens to me in the game I should in
theory you feel you'll definitely feel
it everywhere he comes in go on then
do you worst the impact can be simulated
through electrical stimulation because
we use the actual muscles to react and
then it's it's very precise its national
it's you know exactly where you've been
touched or hit
the concept is probably best explained
in Steven Spielberg's latest offering
can you feel this
[Music]
yeah ready player one explores a
dystopian future where people escape
into a fully immersive virtual reality
world using the exact same idea although
its initially intended for gaming the
suit could later be used as a remote
training tool or even helped in the
rehabilitation of patients in medical
environments production of the Tesla
suit starts in earnest later this year
but will probably come with a
considerably hefty price tag back to
reality
that's crazy Thomas Newton so here's the
reason we've come to the Technology
Center belonging is through one of the
most famous supercar makers McLaren have
been showing me their new high-tech
tools for designing and customizing
their cars there's a new super fast way
to design super fast cars here at
McLaren designers have begun using
virtual reality to turn their ideas from
sketches into three-dimensional images
as quickly as possible this you can see
from what alex is doing here and we can
really do something in a day we can
create a 3d model in a day so it really
is a fast-track to 3d but how long did
it used to take three weeks the
introduction of the gaming technology
came about after the car maker teamed up
with a software startup vector suite it
might be fast and futuristic but the
process still relies on good
old-fashioned human craftsmanship the
biggest thing was to create something
that the retained their their original
skill set which is 2d sketching and it
was enabling them to do that but to do
it using the technology in virtual
reality so what was the reaction when
you came along and said right I'd like
you to start wearing VR headsets to do
your job now yeah the first reaction was
game challenging but once the guys have
got used to it once they've put on the
headset as you can see here after 10
minutes 15 minutes of using it and
interacting with it they started to
really relax into it
now this next innovation
can be used by me in my role as pretend
customer it's a 3d sports car
customization tool so you can kind of
try before you buy or at least see what
bad decisions look like it's choose what
color I want hmm this is an interesting
color and what's next what else can I do
next well we're outside of the car we
look at the wheels there you go you've
got three choices let's go for seems
like we're like super lightweight it was
always going to be the 10-spoke super
light weights and the diamond cut for me
have you ever seen anyone order a car
like this no no not exactly now so let's
go inside the car now
oh look at that so you can have a look
already can I get in there and see what
the interior can go right inside oh wow
the technology used here and in the
design headset is meant to create better
experiences and products according to
Marc and for the innovation cynics out
there how would you respond to critics
that think this is just tech for tech
sake it's absolutely not tech for tech
sake we don't do that we always use the
right tool for the right reasons so I've
designed my car what happens if I don't
like it in real life then we can sell
you another one at a cost of two hundred
and sixty thousand pounds per my bespoke
car I think I'd better just get it right
the first time I'll come and pick up the
car later in the meantime let's join gab
for this week's video games review in
minute you play as this little duck egg
thing and it's a little adventure game
kind of like old school Legend of Zelda
type stuff but you die every 60 seconds
that's the gimmick for it and that
sounds like it should be really annoying
and frantic but it's not it forced you
to think in
pathway really methodical way of going
about things because in 60 seconds
you're gonna die you get a little sort
of inching your way further and further
down the storyline and properly into
where I don't think it's very long I
haven't finished it yet but it's got
this soundtrack that is way more epic
than of game which is all black and
white deserves to be all of its
uncertainty
you cannot flee the future man just got
a rerelease on Nintendo switch and it's
perfect for that console basically play
as a little guy or gal made out of
letters that's the hero and it's kind of
like part puzzle-platformer part sort of
weird little game like think of like
inside but with Scrabble they all do
word puzzles and like there's puzzle the
other day it was basically you presented
with this line of gas all poisonous
gases go through the gas you die and the
only thing you've got to stop any of
that is these little letters and I
managed to figure out that if you put p
on the end of gas it spells gasp and
that means that you could jump in get a
little booster beer and then go on its
way that sounds really simple but it
made me feel like the smartest man in
the world and that's why you should play
Type O man
so we go from two little nice games to
one of the big boys far cry 5 now I've
barely scratched the surface of this
game its massive things that I've been
doing doing though I prefer ended a dog
and turned him into basically an
unkillable killing machine I've run
around with a bear he's my friend now
I've caught some of the biggest fish
ever and I haven't even touched the
storyline yet which is all about this
mad cult taken over this forest II bit
of America but that's one of the cool
things about Bart right is you can do
this amazing story language I'm sure
people put a lot of effort in to do it
or you can just take the sort of weird
tours and mechanics they've made in the
world and just muck around in it that's
what I like you but that's why I think
Faro is good because it sort of K is for
adults and stupid people like me well
that's it for this week's show don't
forget to join us again for more so like
next week and in the meantime follow us
on twitter at sky news swipe see you
again soon bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]